I don't need a man this is my value okay  I stand by my own this is my value so  the question is can you find a man that  can stand next to me and deal with me  yeah but when you say that's your value  to him who's that yeah for me I don't I  don't know  like when you're selling something she  talking about cars when you're selling  something it's you you decide the value  of your tires Market the market does so  so okay that's like me saying okay I'm  Envy like an Envy an NBA player that's  like that's like okay stop stop  interrupting me that's that's like me  saying that I can get a top one percent  guy so I would say I deserve a guy that  can that can that makes half a million  but none are lining up to buy me then  I'm not I'm not worth that that's your  value and so so you can't just tell men  oh I'm still Justin value